pancreatic cancer is the third leading
cause of cancer-related death in the US
and is predicted to become the second
leading cause of cancer mortality by
2020 despite
advances the five-year survival rate
remains less than 7% the majority of
patients present with advanced stage
disease and available treatments with
faux-fur Knox or NAB paclitaxel plus
gemcitabine chemotherapy provide only
modest survival benefit in addition
patients who undergo attempts a curative
surgery plus adjuvant chemotherapy still
have a very poor five-year survival rate
at roughly 15 to 20 percent with 80% of
patients relapsing after resection these
poor outcomes highlight the need for
novel development of biomarkers to
predict patient's survival and treatment
response with potential linkage to
different therapeutic options
in general the term pancreatic cancer
encompasses a mix of pathologies in
which the cells originate in the
pancreas and are thought to be
epithelial in origin
however the question of the cellular
origin of the disease continues to be
debated even with access to modern-day
molecular profiling histology that
distinguishes the exact pathologic
subtype of pancreatic lesions is still
the most clinically informative piece of
data exocrine pancreatic cancers can
have a gland like appearance and are the
most common types of pancreatic cancer
the majority are classified as
pancreatic ductal adenocarcinoma
commonly referred to as PTAC or PDA
other forms of exocrine cancers are rare
but are typically cystic or can be a
sinner cell carcinomas endocrine cancers
are a small subset of all pancreatic
cancers pancreatic neuroendocrine tumors
are classified as functional hormone
producing or non functional non hormone
producing while histologic features are
still used to define and diagnose
pancreatic cancer subtypes more recently
modern molecular techniques such as
next-generation DNA sequencing and RNA
sequencing have been used to further
classify pancreatic cancer subtypes the
hope is to discover better targets and
improve the therapeutic options several
studies have examined gene expression
using micro Ares or RNA sequencing and
have identified distinct RNA signatures
of PTAC collison natal originally
described 3p dak gene expression
subtypes including classical quasi MS n
Komal and exocrine like subtypes Moffat
had out later used a virtual
microdissection approach data from
primary and metastatic P dak tumors to
digitally separate tumor stromal and
normal cell gene expression they
identified two tumor specific signatures
including a classical subtype and a
basal like gene expression program that
resembled the basal subtype of breast
and bladder cancers
moreover they also identified two stroma
specific expression signatures and
demonstrated that combinations of the
stroma and tumor specific subtypes
represent distinct biology with
different prognostic implications the
International Cancer Genome consortium
subsequently defined four major gene
expression subtypes of PTAC including a
pancreatic progenitor class that showed
strong overlap with the Collison and
Moffitt classical subtypes as well as a
squamous classification
that closely resembles the Moffett
basal-like subtype additionally the
International Cancer Genome consortium
study also described and apparently
differentiated endocrine exocrine
subtype and a novel immuno genic subtype
that was associated with evidence of a
significant immune infiltration these
classifications are more similar than
different and several common themes have
emerged the classical or pancreatic
progenitor and the basal like or
squamous neoplastic subtypes have been
validated across multiple studies in
primary and metastatic samples basal
like or squamous tumors Harbor a
significantly worse prognosis than
classical or progenitor tumors these
basal like or squamous tumors also
display more frequent T p53 mutations a
higher pathologic grade and a poor
response to modern chemotherapy regimens
recently the Cancer Genome Atlas project
provided further data suggesting that
the pancreatic progenitor or squamous
subtype was independent of purity in
contrast the addicts or immuno genic
subtype had lower tumor purity the study
also found that among low purity tumors
a higher estimated leukocyte fraction
was associated with immuno genic samples
considering only the high purity samples
in the cohort the squamous samples of
Bailey a tile showed significant overlap
with the basal-like samples defined by
Moffitt at al Weill the Bailey at al
pancreatic progenitor and QALYs ANATEL
classical group largely overlapped the
classical samples defined by Moffitt at
Al these observations suggest that high
purity tumors can be consistently
classified into a basal like or squamous
group and a classical of progenitor
group the strong association of immuno
genic and addicts or exocrine like
subtypes with the low purity samples in
the cohort suggests that these subtypes
may reflect gene expression from non
neoplastic cells
in summary cross comparison of the
studies dis demonstrate that
reproducible biologic subgroups are
emerging in pancreatic cancer
nevertheless a critical question is
whether these subgroups offer more
prognostic or predictive clinical
information about pancreatic cancer than
conventional pathology information
indeed
comparisons of the defined subtypes
suggest some prognostic relevance in
particular the prognosis of the squamous
subtype is worse than that of the
pancreatic progenitor subtype
furthermore there is the question of
whether patients with certain subtypes
of pancreatic cancer are more
appropriate candidates for novel
therapies for example Bailey at
allenford that the immuno genic subgroup
will be more responsive to
immunotherapies their reasoning is
biologically sound but given the recent
history of a lack of benefit from Aminah
therapies and pancreatic cancer this
hypothesis must be thoroughly tested in
clinical trials or at least by
retrospective analyzes other relevant
questions remain that may be obstacles
in moving the subtyping to the clinic
include one can subtypes change within a
tumor ie how can we address intramural
heterogeneity can exposure to therapy
change the subtype of a tumor can we
design novel targeted drugs that can
benefit all subtypes additionally a
byproduct of these deep genetic analyzes
will inevitably be to identify distinct
targetable molecular abnormalities
however in order to benefit an
individual patient these abnormalities
will need to be identified by real-time
methods
two years Peter Bailey is the first
author of the paper really analyzed all
these day genomes 450 odd to try and
understand what are the similarities and
differences about those cancers and
created cancer in particular and then
what sort of opportunities are there for
treatment with existing drugs how can we
select the patient better for a
particular treatment we already have and
that is really the beginnings of
precision oncology or personalized
medicine for pancreatic cancer we will
try and match the right treatment to the
right patient at the right time for the
first time we've defined four subtypes
of pancreatic cancer and the
transcriptional mechanisms that underlie
each of the four subtypes the first
subtype we're pulling a dex for
aberrantly differentiated interconnect
school the second subtype we're calling
pancreatic progenitor the third subtype
we're calling immuno genic and the
fourth subtype we're calling squamous
each of the four subtypes have a number
of key characteristics which seem to
indicate or provide a clue to their key
vulnerabilities and this is the exciting
part of the research the squamous
subtype has a number of transcriptional
programs which we think we can target
the immunogenic subtype has a number of
key vulnerabilities that we think we can
target we can modulate the tumor
microenvironment in some way to allow
the host immune system to destroy the
cancer some of the other types and
subtypes like pancreatic progenitor and
edicts are expressing different types of
genes which we think we can target so
all in all the four subtypes seem to be
associated the number
vulnerabilities which we are excited to
explore these machines that you can see
here imbibe DNA and look for changes
specific changes to the DNA which can
drive a specific subtype of pancreatic
cancer
the one thing that Andrew and the team
of people both here in Australia have
done is produce a very high-quality
library for pancreatic cancer the
library is a fantastic research a
resource for researchers in pancreatic
cancer throughout the world to access
and to relate that data to and to mine
so that we can you know enhance our
understanding of pancreatic cancer
you